welcome to this video was a speedster I
don't know who that is a surname nope
but it's got a ton of five-minute games
okay let's see mmm yeah maybe he's a
quick one speedster but you never know
some people are kind of toying with the
idea and then they're not actually that
quick okay we got a Bishop f4 a queen's
gambit him night age five yes that's one
way to play that and I can try to get
that Bishop quickly one of the main
lines y term we have white has chances
for a slight advantage in this kind of
positions but it's nothing nothing great
it's an early be six but probably I
still have to go before yeah I don't
have c6 or something like that as before
as hanging so I'm going to play a three
and now it now is doing that yeah okay
that's certainly a move order yeah I
think canceling is difficult to do
without so let's do it now the same was
g3 at one point that point is going to
hang so I'm covering it so the question
is do I take on a six here
yeah difficult to let him take are you
threatening okay no not really I can do
that actually start with that move maybe
introduce the idea of playing f5 and
black sometimes okay maybe yeah okay
resolving that tension immediately and
then be fine hmm I thought f5 is a
threat but it seems he is not agreeing
with that idea so f5 he'll take deform
takes takes takes I want to k 1 and then
maybe even if I've as possible now
that's true an interesting question is
if I should go look be worn or something
like that just keep it on the board
let's do it threaten f5 it's an
interesting way to play it's a bit
sharper than allowing all those trades
so f 5 is now really threatened he has
to react to that in some way
you should have six it's the most
obvious way to do it he does not react
to it okay so what is wrong with f5 now
I don't see it ok let's play it first
not second guess myself too much so we
just accepts that this is happening to
him 94 ok I take on f7 look f7 look see
one something terrible happening to me i
don't know i don't i don't see it really
ok let's take yeah that pin is a bit
awkward but I maybe I have not be 5 or
95 I should have been a bit more alert
down now now is now he is so recognizing
it I guess and moves the Queen away I
can maybe t play 95
95 night f to my it looks looks a bit
wrong for black let's see look ff2 I
thought rook f2 maybe 95 but yes I just
like win age three this could be a
problem really okay so maybe I have to
readjust him rupee form rookie for still
night is still Queen 83 okay hmm ah what
is what I would a weird way to play what
did i do here it's that's not really
great this no that's not working
who night you for Rupert III give to
look check Steve form now I have to play
with now maybe I had something better
even but I don't stay though I didn't
see it I don't see it why not time
morning was a bit mystified what took
him so long there but Eric before
unfortunately would would have just one
c 6-r up to 210 justices may be roped it
to us just about winning it's a bit
crazy to allow c6 but maybe he still
wins look T 294 quindi forecheck amazing
melody two wins they didn't CC six at
all but it was a this is just about just
about saving so if he takes the 77 still
works night and queen d 493 I don't get
anything check so I this was this is
this point ok I have to coordinate the
pieces here somehow probably not work
that
check check yep the queen is too strong
you can pick up the beep on
unfortunately Queenie one leads nowhere
but you can just take before if he wants
and now we understood what he needs to
do I can just take that and over let's
chance to be too simple check you chant
you okay yeah anyway I'm resigning it
could have promoted all right ensign
yeah so it was a bit okay I mean I did
simply screw that up allowing f5 is just
just bad for black I just have to refute
it i can go 95 I saw that one move too
late yeah I saw that one move to LA she
took here and now f3 hang so it's still
working it's still working so because if
one hangs yeah I didn't see that you for
hangs at the end so what in that what
did not think therefore mood I mean I
was actually thinking that this also is
good yeah the fact is good but 95 just
ends the game right here so okay anyway
Brooksie one quincy aight thats that
trick here is his out of that tactic now
and 95 tactic and now it gets tricky 95
Teague's yeah rookie for that that I saw
that move but I thought that a queen
edge three I can take that rook so okay
yeah then this is better I i forgot that
after this I can actually take the rook
so this was my problem there i will i
wanted to do this but I i forgot that
the night going has relinquished cover
of that rukon f2 so we got this yeah
okay Wow okay
yeah he overlooked c6 quite clearly but
looked it two wins and that said the
problem chances a bit tough on that just
minus 1 according to the engine
interestingly enough i get the beep horn
and lamb but ok i was spotting c6 but
it's just I've worked it to win Samson
it just just as win e seven chat and
drooped you one yeah looks it to us it's
a bit stronger even but black is winning
in any case check so yeah yeah I don't
have any coordination and chest we can
take the take the beep or phone poor
before on all of the time simply for
some reason didn't do it anyway thanks
for watching